hat der polizei polizist richtig
gehandelt der auf einer demonstration in
dresden drohte schubs mich und du fängst
eine kugel
für die einen ist er ein held weil er
sich allein gegen eine antifa gruppe bei
einer demonstration stellte für andere
ist sein verhalten ein skandal weil er
mit dem einsatz seiner polizeiwaffe
drohte und diese auch mit der hand
berührte die fragliche szene jetzt noch
mal im video und auch die diskussion
darüber
unfassbare worte bei einer demonstration
für mehr flüchtlingsaufnahme in dresden
anhänger der usa dresden der
undogmatischen radikalen antifa wie sie
sich nennen stehen dicht an dicht mit
einen polizisten es wird gedrängelt der
polizist reagiert schubst mich und du
fängst ihre kugel empörte rufe
erscheinen aus den reihen der
demonstranten der polizist weicht zurück
greift sogar zur dienstwaffe sein
versucht die situation zu entschärfen
scheitert nur an drei einsatzkräfte
können die lage entschärfen
der vorfall löste bundesweit kontroverse
reaktionen aus doch wie sehen die
deutschen das verhalten des polizisten
helden polizist oder skandal bild hat
sich umgehört unmöglich
gekippt hat einfach nicht vermisst weg
aber die gehen auch für alles bestraft
ich meine auch irgendwie müssen wir auch
mal für differenziert auch die
sichtweise in frankfurt am main
sie werden die rmn die uniformen und so
werden die herren ich weiß dass das
viele jugendliche sagen respekt vor der
polizei verloren habe und deswegen sie
werden viel mitmachen
deswegen kann ich schon verstehen
tendenziell kritischer die meinung der
menschen in leipzig sein dass polizisten
polizisten das wasser das nicht anders
doch manche wie rentner manfred böhme
aus essen positionieren sich auch ganz
anders
also ich stehe voll hinter den
polizisten aus dem einfachen grunde weil
er alleine auf die leute zugegangen ist
und hat keine drohung so in diesem sinne
ausgestoßen
wenn er aber von der meute dann bedroht
wird wie soll er sich anders wären nach
angaben der polizei dresden hat sich der
polizist inzwischen für sein verhalten
bei der demo entschuldigt die anwendung
der schusswaffe sei nie eine
handlungsoption für ihn gewesen nicht
ausreichend für den innenexperten der
sächsischen grünen valenti lippmann er
meint der vorfall dürfte
disziplinarrechtliche relevanz haben was
ich wohl übersetzen lässt mit der
polizist sollte belangt werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren